from the start of the pandemic public
health england's played a pivotal role
rapidly developing a covid test and
collecting crucial data
on cases and deaths but some say it's
been
slow and over centralized a criticism
echoed by the prime minister at the end
of june
the parts of government that seem to
respond so sluggishly so that
sometimes it seemed like that recurring
bad dream
when you're telling your feet to run and
your feet
won't move this week things are moving
public health england to be replaced by
a new body the national
institute for health protection
incorporating pandemic response work
with the test and trace programme but
one of the architects of public health
england
says any failings lie firmly with the
government
if there's anything that the secretary
of state matt hancock
wants public health england to do by way
of working with
nhs testing trays by way of working with
local authorities
by way of expanding or changing the
testing capacity
he should direct them to do that and
simply trying to move around
the structural architecture doesn't help
anybody at this stage at all
the new organization will be modelled on
germany's institute
which quickly mobilized mass testing it
is part of the federal government but it
is run independently so
um you know the signs that we produce we
can you know
say something about it and and do so
independently nevertheless it is part of
the federal government
but uh you know that is you know it
sounds like there's tension in this but
you can have both
public health england covers more than
covid its roles include obesity
smoking vaccination and heart disease
many say criticism of its work
is unfair scapegoating for many years uh
we were concerned on the
under the former health and social care
select committee
about the defunding of public health and
we we're spending less than four percent
of the health service
budget on public health so it's been
leeched away
local directors of public health have
long felt excluded
but there are worries major
reorganization during a pandemic
will be distracting and disruptive a
spokesperson for the department of
health and social care said
we have always been clear that we must
learn the right lessons from this crisis
to ensure that we are in the strongest
possible position
both as we continue to deal with covid19
and to respond to any future public
health threat
the new institute will be in place by
september
operational as the country braces for
the prospect
of a second spike this autumn laura
bandok sky news